do you think the Internet is helping or
hurting I think I mean I think to the
extent that the internet serves as a
vehicle for mean propagation people can
get their message out otherwise they
might have difficulty doing so so in
that sense it's great right the problem
is that some of the ones who hurled the
greatest amount of venom are the people
who really are against the free exchange
of ideas so the social justice warriors
that come after guys luckily I've
actually been free of most of these guys
maybe because I'm quite reason than my
positions maybe hopefully but I'll make
sure they come after their stores and
some of my people say you don't rate it
yeah so I think that on average is a bit
of both good in that you allow people to
express themselves bad and that there is
one camp of folks that is a lot more
vested in shutting down free exchange so
is that the challenge then of the
Atheist community or the secular
community or the rational community is
that we don't yell as loud right so how
do we then line up in a way versus
versus the trolls versus the angry mob
how do you get sane people to band
together well at the very least and I
often admonish my academic colleagues
for this who don't participate in this
in this great public discourse right
they're very interested in doing their
very narrow research but yet they're shy
away from talking about these bigger
issues even though their professors I
mean you're all about me and propagation
if your professor yeah and so what I
would do at least what I do it my
limited sphere of influence is to try to
get my colleagues to weigh in on these
issues so that we could have academics
Wayne and not just the trolls yeah does
that work very well I haven't been very
successful because most are terrified of
their shadows yeah so what does that say
then that it's not just I guess it's
coming from every angle well it's coming
from politicians and it's coming from
the media people and it's coming from
the professor's not just well i would i
would add cowardice as part of the seven
deadly sins i would make it a deadly
sins and how about cowardice it's I'm
astonished at how cowardly most people
are there if and i even get people come
to me and say you know I mean you do
great science your non-scientists why do
you weigh in on this
because I can't help it because it's I
feel that it's my job to weigh in on
issues that are nonsensical like the
ones we discussed earlier yeah that's
part of my job description yeah you know
I feel the same way actually sometimes I
think when I'm when I'm tweeting about
this stuff or when I'm writing about it
or whatever it is I think I wish I
didn't have to talk about this stuff you
know in a weird way because it's so
obvious to me you know that the atheists
and the seculars but we're on the right
side of letting everyone I want to treat
everyone as shitty as everyone else they
wouldn't be treated as well as everyone
else you know I mean I don't want to be
treated better than anyone or worse just
treat me the same shitty way you treat
everybody else a lot of times when I'm
in New York City that's what I think
like everyone if there's every race
there there's every color there's every
ethnicity everything and it's like
everyone hates each other but no one's
killing anybody pretty much exactly any
any final thoughts this I mean I could
talk to you all day well hopefully I'll
be back again soon I wanted to
congratulate you on your move to this
network oh thanks great to meet you in
person and it's weird how Twitter works
right we've done this we've never spoken
more than 140 characters and yet I feel
like I know you're very well yeah there
you go all right well you guys can check
out gads YouTube page will annotate to
it so there should be something if
you're watching on YouTube right over
here and I thank you very much thank you
and yeah this is just the beginning of
the types of stuff we're going to be
doing now that we run or a TV the new
set is coming and the show will
officially launch I think it's the
second week in September but I also
check with my lawyers thanks for
watching everybody